Danny wrote in is there a fad from any
time that you wish would come back or a
fad you would never want to see again
most fads I would never want to see
again I think and the one that's coming
back now is the full sweatsuit I don't
know in my neighborhood you see a lot of
people walking around during the day
with the the matching uh sort of like a
tracksuit type of thing like the thick
sweat sweat pants and sweatshirt
material where the pants match the the
sweatshirt same color and everything
same color and everything and I'm not
I'm not into that and I wish that that
hadn't come back if it's coming back
maybe my neighborhood is just very
unfashionable and it's not coming back I
don't know well did you see a
Kickstarter that circulated this week
about the male Romper do you know what a
romper is I mean I think that would be a
travesty if that was to happen I didn't
couldn't tell if that was for real or
not it is oh it it is for Real it's like
a it's like a onesie design for men that
is uh both short shorts and a tank top
combined into one article of clothing
it's kind of disturbing was that ever in
though like is that something coming
back or is that a new thing it would be
a new thing it would be a new thing
you're sure about that yeah I'm pretty
sure I couldn't tell you I have no idea
I don't remember seeing that but it's so
actually wer what wasn't there like a um
oh how am I forget Sean connory didn't
Shan connory sometimes wear sort of like
a onesie in some of the old James Bond
movies or something like that I think
you get to a point in Celebrity Status
where you're able to just pull off
anything and it's maybe not so much of a
trend as his own statement that he's
able to make interesting a fad that is
coming back is the sort of artisanal
shaving thing which used to just be
known as shaving before plastic and mass
industrialization right with like a
beaver hair or I don't even know what it
is uh shaving brush and the hot lather
machine and a single blade and all that
that that sort of has come back yeah
that's coming back with the hipsters the
answer that I would provide is
absolutely 100% fanny packs fanny packs
are convenient I mean you yeah
absolutely you don't have to rely on
your Pockets things can slip out of your
pockets you have everything you'd ever
need right in front of you you can zip
it up you can put it through your belt
loop so as long as you have your pants
you have all your belongings with you it
doubles as a belt I think fanny packs
need to come back today if you want to
see fanny packs um you just go to the
touristy areas of Rome on a busy day and
it's Fanny Pack's Galore you know rarely
do I speak about an issue this
passionately I think Fanny Pacs have to
come back I I don't even want to see
what memes are going to be on the Reddit
discussion forum 24 hours from now
relating to you and fanny packs I would
propose fanny pack Fridays uh well it's
a good thing that we work from home on
Fridays let's put it that way um I I
want those snap bracelets to come back
oh yeah those are pretty cool I'm just
kidding I was I was somewhere over the
weekend and actually saw someone tossing
them they sort of turned uh you know
that game where you try to toss sort of
like a two bean bags connected with a
rope onto ladder ball I think it's
called that's correct it's ball
connected to a a rope or whatever they
were tossing the snap bracelets I don't
even know where you get snap bracelets
right now and trying to get them to snap
onto the ladder steps that you would use
for ladder ball interesting I think all
these fashion trends have an initial
phase and then for 10 years or so they
disappear entirely and then they become
retro and they come right back I think
that's what's happening now at the snap
bracelets cuz that was in during The
'90s Carpenter's jeans were sort of in
towards the I think the end of the 9s
and you probably even know what that is
and that's fine or overalls Carpenters
jeans are sort of like the bottoms of
overalls where you have like a place
where you can put in a hammer and it was
when baggier jeans were in okay and I
hope that doesn't come back sounds like
an alternative to the fanny pack with
all the stuff that you can carry in
there yeah a lot of these fads have to
do with carrying stuff around have you
noticed that like different ways to
bring your things from one place to
another you have to have all your things
on you as one I think we're better off
just carrying around less stuff that
that's that's my view all right that's
it we've got a great bonus show coming
up for you today